hello welcome back to gang sports
coverage of e3 2016 I'm delighted to be
joined by Edie beech the lead designer
on Civilization six Firaxis games you
are flying the flag for Firaxis at e3
this year absolutely
you got some folks back at the booth as
well as showing off six we got we got
three members of dev team that are here
with us and I'm out to talk to GameSpot
fill you in on all the details anything
you want to know about six-six awesome
we got a bunch of questions but if you
have any questions in the chat I know
these civilizations fans that community
are always very good with their specific
questions so I'm gonna be keeping an eye
on the GameSpot chat and also the twitch
shot so make sure you get them in there
I mean you know save is the godfather of
sort of for X Games it must be hard to
try and reinvent these games every every
iteration right you were also the lead
on fives I was the lead for the two
expansions oh all right okay the gods
and kings in brave new world it's really
cool because this is the 25th
anniversary right the very first
civilization so it's like the perfect
year to be putting out a new title and
we've had a quite a few years to kind of
stew on hmmm what we're gonna do this
time basically ever since brave new
world came out it was like right into
SIVs right six for me
so civilization six has a couple key new
concepts and we have a video that we're
showing here in the background then
we'll be able to pick out some things
and highlight them yeah if there's
number one thing is what we're doing
where we call it unstacking the cities
right so everything have been crammed in
that one tile before all the buildings
all the wonders the world there now have
to find a place you have to find out
where outside that city you want to put
them on the map and all the positioning
of all those elements outside the city
is really strategically important so
they're whole new you know kind of layer
of decisions yeah you're faced with that
you hadn't been faced with before and so
that's sort of what's really freshened
up the gameplay made it really exciting
yeah so talk to some of those obviously
it's it's hard to sort of try to imagine
them right now but presumably you there
are some sort of tiles you want to keep
more protected than others perhaps like
what how does that sort of work what the
way it works is there twelve different
types of what we call districts
that our tiles that you dedicate outside
the city for a specific pursuit so it's
a campus is your scientific district or
a holy site is your a religious district
and you can't have all 12 around the
same city right so you're gonna have to
specialize your cities in the video the
first city had a we haven't put any
districts in but you can see that some
farms went in around that and then the
second city here we settled that on the
ocean which gave us some boosts in our
new research system which we can talk
about for a while if we want now we're
connecting a trade route back to the
original city and one of the changes we
made is all the way all the improvements
and roads work we've sort of also
revamped that for civilization six so
now early in the game all of your roads
are built through the traders and the
network of trade routes that you
establish sort of right you the default
layer of roads you can add some as
specific ones later when you get to
military engineers but for right now
it's sort of the traders are going to
establish how the cities are connected
up here we're going to put in our first
district we're gonna have a holy site
the game will show you the bonuses you
can get from different places you want
to put it people want to worship like
with majestic mountains in the
background come up with for all those
different 12 different types of district
what should it be next to and what the
really long rules like that the
religious one India is easy to figure
out what would make sense there so now
we're gonna show you what happens with
wonders wonders are also pulled out from
the city so we're gonna build the
pyramids pyramids have to go into desert
tile this having to have a desert nearby
and we've brought back the wonder movies
that we used to have in sit for where
it's a specific animation of how that
Wonder is built but now it's happening
in engine outside your city exactly
what's going on if you have an army
camped on your borders you'll see the
army in the animation video it you know
it's very fun and cool and sort of you
get a lot more investment into sort of
the personalization of all your cities
because you specialize them you've sort
of lay them out piece by piece you get
to see all the wonders go into play
you also see throughout this video that
we have with the new
our system that we have we have a time
of day system right okay so we can you
know change it from sunrise through to
noon time lighting and then onto sunset
into the evening when we get this is
kind of a video that walks you through
the course of a single game of
civilization so by the end we'll be you
know in modern times and you'll see that
the cities are lit up with lights and
it's fun you can play like that if you
like right you know set it to cycle
through day/night cycles as you play or
you can just keep it on a specific
setting if there's like a certain type
of day that you just like the way it
looks in or you know art style one of
the great things about civilization is
watching that sort of drive to the
future and how you guys having stuff
like nuclear war this time Randy keeping
similar systems in previous games or
revamping the big change that you have
to think about in terms of combat is now
that we've spread the cities occur
across the map hmm now there are a lot
of things that are vulnerable because
they're out away from your city right
and even if you if you're strong enough
to defend your city maybe you've got
walls there and those kind of things
yeah the city core is not going to be
captured and we won't lose the entire
city but you could have the science
district outside it just rampage by
barbarians that could come through and
pillage it I think we were just seeing
some barbarian combat on the right video
there and so you you have to pick and
choose what's going on in every tile
that has like this kind of districts can
be pillage individually if you're
pillaging a science dot tile you you
gain science for your civilization
you're like stealing all the plans for
for what they were doing on their
scientific research and with nuclear
weaponry we do the same thing where
exactly where that nuke is striking is
going to be very important in terms of
knowing what its effect is going to be
in your city here's here's our first
leader we are trying to pick big fun
very flavorful personalities for a
leader is Gandhi still Opie but so we
chose Teddy Roosevelt for it for the
Americans you know just the coolest guy
the Rough Rider he's out west he's you
know fighting off the Spanish on San
Juan Hill and Cuba he's all over the
place plus what we're doing with the
leaders this time is we are giving them
all
a specific diplomatic agenda from
history and that's how they like to play
civilization right this is a quick look
at the new civic and government system
so now it's a little bit of sieve for
it's a little bit us if I've each of
those cards there it's like a social
policy from sieve five but they get
configured into a government that has
those different slots there right and so
you have to both pick a government and
then figure out which social policies
you want to be using at a given point in
time you actually end up reconfiguring
your government like we're enacting new
legislation now we're gonna be you know
really good at you know building up our
districts or whatever so there's a lot
of fun and flexibility and and sort of
configurability in terms of how you like
to roleplay your sieve that comes out of
the government system yeah excuse to me
over the past few years that the the
strategy scene has been growing it's
sort of returning to where it was maybe
in the 90s in some ways in terms of
popularity or at least the flow of games
and I'm really curious because you know
you're obviously adding things that make
the game more complex which speaks to
the fans
how do you play test this with new
audiences maybe who aren't traditionally
into strategy how do you incorporate
approachability when it our
accessibility when it comes to a game
that is so complex in so many ways yeah
and initially the art style is different
and we've talked about people we're
gonna have a quick playing multiplayer
games there's a lot of feel like oh is
it gonna be dumbed down but you're
absolutely right you hit it right spot
on that this game is is more complex
even than some 5 was but what we're
trying to do is really attack it with
just o vastly improved user interface
okay that's going to bring a lot of
information out so you could see when
you're placing a district there before
there were no rules you to memorize in
your head about like whether you know we
are going to give you all that
information and bring it out for you so
you'll say I'm going to take a holy site
and put it on the map and it will
compute all the bonuses for every single
tile and you'll just be able
you'll be able to get tooltips and stuff
so you can see where those bonuses are
coming from and start to understand you
know ahead of time because then then the
next time you said all a new city you'll
be able to look for those things and say
aha near the mountainside it's very
interesting mountains used to be an
awful place yeah certainly and now
everyone wants me like I need them for
my holy sites and we give science
bonuses for mountains to keep it
observatories up there
so mountains are actually very very
useful now it's yeah Peters question
about accessibility spot-on I mean
especially here's a great example of
what combats doing outside the city all
right you have to defend things you can
see a districts or pillage or poorer
holy soil looks like a mess here it's
smoking and ruin this is an Egyptian a
cat attack we saw Cleopatra appear on
there yeah briefly she's the leader of
Egypt her agenda is she likes to ally
with strong leaders so you think about
historically Julius Caesar and Mark
Anthony those were her friends she kind
of avoided getting conquered by Rome by
friending room yeah so that's how she
plays again she wants the strong big
beefy military SIVs to be her allies to
protect her
stay away Gandhi so in this particular
game
now we're besieging her city this isn't
gonna go well for Cleopatra
right so we're gonna see her boo moaning
the loss of Egypt here but you know
again you can get a good example of how
combat is pulled out from the city as
well right and they're specific a fella
Satya Patra said and so we're saying
about I guess the accessibility issue
there you know Jake Solomon's team on
XCOM seemed to do a really good job of
actually making a game accessible and
I'd love to build ex con games and they
were credibly difficult to penetrate and
have you guys learned from that and have
you also learned have you learned
anything from beyond our thought team
what they were working on as well
because presumably that was intended but
while you're working on yeah I'm a big
XCOM fan and sunk hundreds of hours into
all of our XCOM titles and so I love
those games there are snippets of a
little UI that you'll see pulled rank so
XCOM always has a movement boundary you
select a soldier it shows you exactly
how far you can get in that turn with
that and like I've never been able to
figure out what the XCOM movement rules
are how right how fast you go up and
down ladders and jump off things that's
always been very confusing yeah you
don't need to know those because the
movement boundaries there so we did
exactly the same thing he actually did
change up the movement rules a little
bit because I wanted to reflect the
terrain a little bit better but we just
put in that blue movement boundary and
all of a sudden it's clear what's going
on all right
and what about some stuff like like new
cultures new nations you know we're
seeing a lot of familiar faces here at
the Americas and Cleopatra why not well
there has always been some sort of like
underserved parts of the world like
Africa and South America as well are you
adding new cultures into the game there
gonna be 18 civilizations when we
release and we absolutely are going to
have some brand new ones that have never
been the series before they're not the
ones we're gonna announce first right
fair enough tried-and-true ones first so
that's got it we've announced four so
far so it's America Egypt the two that
we saw here and then China and Japan so
the those are the four announced
civilizations but we're gonna hit new
areas hit civilizations that we haven't
covered in the series before and one
thing that we are going to do is it it's
always struck me very interesting how
our fans love to play on a true earth
map right yeah and that's a very very
popular mode for civilization and I
think we we didn't service that well
enough and so five right so we with only
18 civilizations we can't hit all the
spots the world right out eight but we
have plans for trying to balance those
true or sets oh that ups much better
than we don't worry if if the British
arm has Ireland's as well I'll forgive
you don't worry about it it's okay and I
mean another thing that's very popular
would save five is is I forget what
they're called but like demo versions
where they just filled them full of AI
racine this to explode on on to games
yeah a lot of play games on YouTube have
you done anything to wait we actually
the great thing is that what I'm
Symphony dn't start as the lead designer
I started as the lead AI engineer right
and so it's my job to get the AI tuned
up and I actually might was sort of my
job before so if I've launched for about
two years to set up those AI auto play
games and watch that no better man and I
always thought they were very cool yeah
but I never thought they would catch on
the way they have all right there's like
wow these people are all doing what I
did for jobs other people play yeah down
there exactly so one of the things we
did for sip six is we're like we need to
get our
playing in that automated mode as early
as we possibly can right and so we
actually got a big flat screen TV and
stuck it out in the hallway right
outside our lead engineers office and
for four months now it's just 24/7 rice
running water and it's great it catches
you know if somebody introduces a crash
or a biography yeah that will find it
people go out to to lunch you know and
they're leaving the office and they're
looking at what's going on the big
screen right up and they're like what's
the state of the world yeah yeah and we
can tell a lot about how the AI is
performing everyone's just seeing the
game in action all the time you know
maybe you don't get to play into the
late ages that often when you're you
know if you're not a for sure testers
yeah yeah but you see it up on the big
screen there so it's actually being
great and so it's good um you know
there's a II I ought to play games
they're gonna be supported pretty well
because all the time also we haven't got
to a much longer to wait for it either
October 21st of this year is when it's
coming out yeah be check you so much for
coming on and talking to us about
Civilization 6 enjoy the rest of your a3
all right it's been a big pleasure thank
you guys thank you very much for
watching I'm almost done with my stint
on the show today we're alive until 6
p.m. s-s in our three hours my final
demo of the of my slot is on in just a
minute
Todd Herod's coming on to talk about
Skyrim so stick around
you